the
votes that you have cast the folks that
you get to go
vote between today and let's remind
everybody to vote early between today
and sunday
november 1st are going to have an impact
on people you may never meet people who
may never know your name
but because you here in florida voted in
your numbers
voted with your voice and the power of
your voice
you will very likely determine the
outcome of this election
and so i am here on behalf of joe biden
and myself
to say thank you
to say thank you and look
i don't have to tell everybody here
there is so much at stake in this
election
there is so much at stake who watched
the debate
um well we've already we've actually had
two i guess
and we've had two debates but i i really
meant that town hall did you all see joe
biden in that town hall
wasn't he spectacular and you know
in this election folks have got two
choices
and i think that what we saw in those
town halls
last week really made clear that there
is a distinct difference
between the two choices being presented
to the american people
on the one hand you have joe biden
who is dedicated to building on the
success
that he and president barack obama
created with the affordable care act
which brought health care to over 20
million people
an initiative that was born out of an
understanding and belief that the access
to health care should be a right and not
just a privilege of those who can afford
it
the affordable care act which said it's
not right it just ain't right
when people who have pre-existing
conditions like diabetes high blood
pressure breast cancer
that they'd be denied coverage because
an insurance company says oh we don't
cover if you have a pre-existing
condition
and they got rid of that ban and they
said no longer
can you deny people access to health
care if they have a pre-existing
condition
joe biden has been fighting for working
people his entire life
and on the other hand you have donald
trump
who right now with his boy bill barr is
in the united states supreme court
trying to sue against the affordable
care act and if they
are successful they will get rid of
coverage that came to over 20 million
people
they will lose and lose the protections
for all of the people who need
coverage if they have pre-existing
conditions this is what they're up to
and it is shameful
and it is shameful there is a clear
contrast here
on the one hand you have joe biden who
is saying we're going to have middle
class tax cuts
taxes will not be raised on anyone
making less than 400 000
a year on the other hand you have donald
trump
who passed a tax bill benefiting the top
one percent in the biggest corporations
of america
in florida you know that right now
people are hurting people are suffering
in florida right now one in eight
floridians
is describing members of their household
as being
hungry we're in the midst of a hunger
crisis in america
in florida right now one in five
floridians is describing
themselves being unable to pay their
rent in september
but yet this man donald trump would like
you to believe
everything is okay because you see his
measure of the success of the economy
is based on the stock market
our measure is based on how working
people
are doing and how are you doing
so we got a lot of work to do we got a
lot of work to do when we think about
the fact that
we're all wearing masks the only reason
i'm not wearing one at the moment is
because i'm this far
away from everybody why are we wearing
masks because we're in the midst of a
pandemic well let's remember the history
the recent history on this
thanks to bob woodward we know
donald trump was informed in january
january 28th of the nature of this
pandemic
he was informed that it was lethal in
proportion it would kill
five times as many people as the flu he
was informed
it could hurt children he was informed
that it was courageous and
air-bound and what did he do he stood
at rallies and he stood before the
american people and he didn't tell you
what he knew
imagine folks if you knew on january
28th what he knew
on january 28th and what you might have
done
or been able to do to protect your
family
to protect your children knowing that it
is inevitable that maybe there might
have to be some time that people have to
stay home from work
and perhaps you could have planned for
that
but instead he held on to that
information he covered it up
and then he told the people us
we the people well you're on one side of
his ledger
if you don't wear a mask you're on
another side of his ledger if he wears a
mask
what's that about and see this is the
difference between
a donald trump and a joe biden because
joe biden stands for the people
with the people he knows that this
election will be conducted by the people
and so that's what's ahead of us what is
ahead of us
is to fight it's to fight knowing that
we don't
want a president of the united states
who spends full time
trying to sow hate and division between
us that's not who we
are we know that in the beauty of the
diversity of who we are
the vast majority of us have so much
more in common than what separates us
and we're here right now standing in the
rain
because we know we are better than this
and we
know that the strength of our democracy
is in the strength of the people and
that the people
are prepared to fight for their country
based on our love of our country we will
fight for our country
and that's what this election is about
and you know here in florida with the
exception of some of the
great members of congress and some of
the mayors and all the folks you know i
also know you got some other folks who
are elected in florida
i'm not going to mention any names um
but here's the thing all over this
country
people are trying including this
president
to suggest to you that you can't trust
our election system they're trying to
confuse folks about
voting they're trying to suggest that
that there's somehow
there's something that lacks integrity
about our system because you see
they're trying to confuse folks about
your power to vote they're trying to
confuse
folks about how to vote but we're
smarter than that
and we know the power that we have when
we vote and here's the point that i want
to make
sometimes not only do we have to sit
back and know that we've got to vote to
honor all of the ancestors who fought
for our right to vote people like the
late great
john lewis you know we know that we need
to
to vote to honor we just honored the
100th anniversary of the 19th amendment
all those suffragettes
who fought for the right for women to
vote
we also fight for all of those who
understood black women didn't get to
vote until 1965
we honor the ancestors but we we also do
as we know this and this is what i want
to ask you and then i'm going to close
my comments because i want you to get
off the brain
and i'll leave you with this we have to
ask and please get back in your cars get
in your cars and i'll i'll talk louder
[Laughter]
here's the thing i you know when all
these people all over the country all
these powerful people trying to put
roblox in
right you know they've been picking up
the drop boxes right so people can't
find it hard to find where the dropbox
is to early vote
they've been trying to suppress the vote
they've been purging the voter rolls
and you have to sit back and ask why are
these powerful people
trying to make it so difficult for us to
vote and here is the answer
because they know our power they know
when we
vote we win they know when we
vote that we vote for justice we vote
for fairness they
know we know what's on the ballot in
2020 justice is on the ballot in 2020.
economic justice is on the ballot in
2020.
criminal justice reform is on the ballot
in 2020 reproductive justice is on the
ballot in 2020 climate justice is on the
ballot in 2020.
we know what we have at stake and we
know our power and that's why we will
vote
every day until election day and get
this
thing done thank you
[Music]
[Music]
and they often criticize you for your
skin tone wanna hold your head high
cause you're a pretty woman
get your runway stride home and keep it
going girl live your life
follow me follow me follow me girl be
yourself